the curse of Lala yeah I apologize
over the past week lawyer ona has cursed
me with a terrible cold that I'm just
now getting over so we're gonna power
through this review I don't have a cold
right now that's not a problem we're
gonna talk about this movie the curse of
La Llorona is the latest in the
conjuring universe this is a spin-off of
sorts very loosely connected to the
other conjuring films and this one is
about the folktale known as the weeping
woman she's an urban legend of sorts
that tells of a woman who long ago
drowned both of her children in a river
and today she hunts other children that
she can steal away she attracts children
by crying lures them in and then kills
them in some way I guess because she's a
spirit demon as a folktale if you've
ever done any research surrounding La
Llorona there's actually a lot there
that's really creepy very eerie and I
was excited to see a film that hopefully
delved into that and gave some backstory
and made you feel like you were watching
something that was more than just a
series of scare scenes unfortunately
that's exactly what this film is the
first I would say the first act was
actually alright the beginning was
investing I was like okay that's not bad
I mean the title booms on the screen I
was like okay that's cool okay
something's happening alright this is
kind of exciting and then you get
introduced to the characters and you
meet a family and you see she works as
an agent for child endangerment and
that's good that's a good link for her
and some of the first few scenes that
build up this woman and her creepiness
and what she can do were really
effective it's the second act really
that becomes just a long series of
scenes where you're building up to a
jump-scare
and they find effective ways to do that
they're in a car the windows are being
rolled down there's a girl with an
umbrella and she moves the umbrella
around and you can see La Llorona in
different places and they do this quite
often and you can really feel like the
writers just didn't have anything to
work with which is not true there is so
much to work with in that folktale
there is so much they could have done
that they just ignored to focus on an
average Los Angeles family in the 1970s
like this should have been in Mexico
imagine how beautiful this movie would
have looked if it was shot in Mexico I
mean this is a Mexican folk tale why is
it in boring we've seen it a thousand
times Los Angeles with some average
family it just doesn't make sense like
it seems like they had gold there like
they really could have just went for
this awesome folktale with so much lower
behind it and shot it in a really cool
place that you don't usually see feature
films in of this scale coming from a
franchise universe but they just shot it
in Los Angeles and to me that's just a
big missed opportunity I'd say one of
the bigger pluses of the film though is
the acting I think Linda Cardellini and
Raymond Cruz are both really good the
kids are also excellent really good kid
performances which this film relies a
lot on that because this is a ghost that
takes the kid and so the kids are gonna
have a lot of screen time I could sync
your movie and they did a great job
the acting I would say is probably the
best part of the film the cinematography
is fine it feels very standard it just
there's many scenes that look exactly
like a James Wan movie but without the
innovation this is a first-time director
for a feature and it definitely feels
like he's attempting to make this film
fit into the universe without making it
feel like it's of its own there's
something I'm noticing about the
conjuring universe films and it is
troubling just about every single one
that isn't a James Wan conjuring movie
save for literally just Anabel creation
they all feel very inconsequential it's
almost like they're told to not be
better than the conjuring because they
all feel like they're not trying to be
better than the conjuring I can't
imagine the studio is actually enforcing
that that would be really detrimental to
your franchise but that's what these
films are starting to feel like the
majority of this universes films that
aren't directed by James Wan
just feel like cash grabs because the
entire third act of this movie is set
basically in her house I won't give you
away any spoilers but it's really clear
that they're doing their best to make
these movies on the cheap which makes
sense
you make horror on the cheap you make a
good bang for your buck that's just how
it goes
I understand how that works is something
that I will eventually probably try to
do myself so I'm not talking down to
them for that I'm just saying that it
feels like they're operating within a
boundary with the way they're writing
this like if they shot it in Mexico it
would absolutely be a better film I mean
I have no doubt to be a better film but
it'd also be a more expensive film
probably because you'd have to go across
country and you'd have to you know lug
all the gear out there instead of just
shooting a nice Los Angeles a block away
from the studio where you're gonna edit
it and it just feels like they aren't
trying hard enough to make the best film
they could and they're just making very
smart business choices which is
disappointing with a folktale as cool as
this still the first 25 minutes were
okay and I was actually invested and I
felt like I was excited about what could
happen next but then the tropes started
to pile in she visits a priest the
priest knows about the history the
priest explains the history okay we've
seen this a thousand times before she
goes back home everyone in the house
starts to see this thing but nobody
wants to talk about it and nobody wants
to admit that it's real despite the fact
that if they just got together and
talked about it maybe they could start
making a plan and things could get
interesting but no we want to have more
jump-scare scenes then she goes back to
the priest again and gets more
exposition and you're just like okay at
this point you've lost me it was a cool
setup it's a cool antagonist but they
just didn't do anything with it I'm
gonna give the curse of La Llorona
a d-plus for me this was about on the
same level as the nun not very scary
just some sequences billed to noises and
you just don't really feel invested in
the story that's the most important part
and I wasn't unfortunately I wanted to
though I wanted to and this could have
been a lot better guys thank you so much
as always for watching and thank you for
dealing with my crappy voice right now
speak
of voice there's something I noticed
about the trailer for this movie and
trailers in general have you ever
noticed that when a film is titled a
title where the studios are afraid maybe
the general public won't be able to
pronounce it
they have voice over in the trailer
pronounce it for you
look out for that next time you see a
movie with a weird title if there's no
voiceover for the entire trailer and
then all of a sudden there's voiceover
at the end speaking the title it's
probably because the studio is afraid
you won't be able to pronounce it that's
just my two cents for the day on studio
pronunciation trailer or voices guys
thank you so much as always for watching
look forward to more reviews very soon
and if you like this you can click right
here and get that I almost got through
it without a problem and then right at
the end ha now you guys know what it is
[Music]